but then I'm gonna okay so this is the
easiest this is the easiest staff we
wish to learn how to take his energy and
aim it into the mid foot of the back
foot if you put your foot on that line
it's very difficult once you understand
how to do things then he can push it's
just a matter where you're putting it
but in the beginning angle your hips on
this sector
position
not
this is also a throw this is slightly
chin then the chest is not key in with
backpack
so as the chin goes in and down my chest
is not our chest stays out
my chest is out and there is almost like
an expansion and a lowering of the last
so and this would be no expansion of the
lots with their down expansion I'm here
like this my chest stays open I don't
want to stick my chest out
here then the second is the angle of the
arm and the depth with that lap chest
expansion that works with the chin on
the top of the head there is a place
where this arm finds a groove where it's
feeding off of that structural integrity
and then not holding it with the arm
muscles like here with my bicep okay or
here with my forearm so its height its
depth and it's with our very important
so as you are feeling your muscles do
one or the other
try a different one you're the easiest
ways to try to look like a teacher but
that's not so easy but we get in our own
way but you can't play with it so for
example I'm here like that my doing my
bicep I'm gonna try extending if I come
out here like that you're gonna feel it
in your inner does way bring it back in
alignment you see that if you're down
here like this you're going to give it
at the top of the forearm so bring it up
so table for our comes up energy
I said are we sent out okay
let's try these things okay so what
we're looking at for a kind of
structural integrity that allows me to
manipulate monitor without having to use
muscles now I do it more with a unified
map okay not those individual muscles
were trying to get rid of that four out
of the five separately with them okay so
we're now going to do the same exercise
with two hands the same thing you'll
feel the same thing build it up performs
the truth though pushing and building
your bicep stir to bet if you have these
weird angles or your hands dirty
campaign its laterally too far in loudly
too far out it's in the deltoids so chin
from the head back foot back expanding
last down then I find a groove where
somehow my arms can maintain
conditioning without the arm muscles
being utilized in an isolated private
unas now as we set up this drill the
drill itself has set up a center to
Center connection okay ladies pushing
and I'm here so my weight should be on
my back foot all I'm going to do with
this end of the
shift weight that's the test then I give
the drill again he's on the back foot
and I should wait I'm not throwing him
he's pushing driving driving the back
foot
he's in the back foot and my you'll
get this little percussion hey I'm here
yeah I know the same feeling aha
I just keep it and move it forward so
don't try to change me I changed a few
this same walk I locked everything
forward same thing goes on your head
when I'm getting and I'm here are you
going to do it I don't go like that
I take this energy and I put it in the
box and then I go be driving drive okay
Luke is doing the same thing it chest up
chin knock and then that back leg okay
so as he goes my arms stay straight
wouldn't see my Center so they need
energy out the same organization that he
is using to demonstrate via projection
is the same energy that I'm using to be
projected this is not hiding this is
Barney organization so you can
immediately see he has organization and
he shifts his weight can always take it
out but you not actually organization
reason lock your body
he goes and he moves that thing and it's
a golden rule the more projectable you
are before you understand how to have a
projector projecting body alright so
you're trying to feel that he goes oh
you'll get it okay
so what do you see I didn't take that
step and you see that because originally
he's not too small right so I'm bringing
them in one by relaxing I bring them in
the door and then there's gotta be again
in order for them so you get the lock
who gets there like already thinking
about the Academy okay you have to learn
to bring them in in all of your Kiyomasa
there's a kid that brings them into
range so you can't be like nagas where
you keep them out bring him in bring
them in and now he sees if I'm gonna go
round more round you see and now he's
loading up the truck and I can do it do
you guys get it so please feel you feel
he's out there you're gonna tell us it's
gonna be very small so I go yeah you see
I'm a comedian section one boom and then
you can get it or you can be you get and
you can really get it then boom and
you'll feel it do you see that so if you
cannot win it make them do it ask them
to do it but stop projecting weight is
not projectable into a deeper sense
let's start with hip width and then push
into deeper Sam's hit with whoa push
here all of those are the standard my
philosophy I'm here
no witch why I have been good wait is
that I was engaged in your posterior
chain so I want you to you know you're
like what the hell is that
well let's just start by like oh I'm
gonna activate this - you got that so if
I was trying to stuff like that you can
hold me and I'll actually be pushed by
this blue is going to be activated via
that Bigfoot kind of like a swap so I'm
here I Drive that I'll feel it in that
blues not like this photography stuff -
groundhog
so I keep them towards the lock which i
doing to stay here now I keep that lock
and then I'm going to activate the glue
okay
right and then you kind of push me
raha and then I try I'm not going over
here that's not a balanced row I'm not
going to go around him I feel any weight
and I go right
[Applause]
you have to find it you can't go
wherever you want it but it feels the
same he's charging my foot okay that's
[Applause]
[Music]
one Oh God you guys are making is you
don't want to injure because you already
feel close enough
let us be venture bending your arm if
you keep arm extended everything moves
not there okay